the only way that the gun control
proposals which you will see on twitter
instagram facebook youtube right now
which they trend because of the
algorithms
unbiased right neutral algorithms
absolutely when you look at those trends
the only way for their proposals to work
is if
all of america is a gun-free zone if
there are any guns we have 400 million
let's say you reduce it down to 50 that
would not stop mass shootings that would
not that would not make a dent and does
anyone here actually think we could get
rid of
two-thirds of half the guns in the
united states of america this is also
what's funny when you hear people argue
against the drug war and they they say
well you know it'll put drug dealers out
of business right they won't move to
arms or underage sex trafficking drug
dealers the cartel they don't see
themselves in the business of drugs they
see themselves in the business of not
paying taxes whatever they can sell
illegally to be clear so the only way
that these current proposals coming from
the left could help is if the entire
united states was a gun-free zone and we
all agreed